moyens pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur le
télégramme darty france vous pouvez
prendre part aux débats à donner votre
opinion et interpeller nos invités au
sommaire de ce lundi 18 octobre marine
le pen et eric zemmour doit fier se
rassembler c'est la question qu'on vous
pose ce soir en première partie de cette
émission on est en vos réactions sur
notre compte et d g robert ménard le
maire de béziers implore en tout cas le
polémiste toujours pas candidat officiel
d'unir leur candidature en attendant
elle la campagne continue pour d'autres
les élèves emmanuel macron anne hidalgo
jean luc mélenchon plusieurs des
principaux candidats déclarés ou non se
sont affrontées par médias et meetings
interposé ce week end compte rendu et
des barres à suivre à la une ce soir
également les relations russie otan que
se passe-t-il entre moscou et l'alliance
atlantique
on tentera de voir plus clair dans un
instant la russie annonce suspende sa
mission auprès de l'otan et celle auprès
de l'alliance et moscou répliques après
le retrait des accréditations aux fins
de l'alliance de huy représentant russe
sur fond d'accusations d'espionnage ont
démêlera le vrai du faux avec nos
invités
[Musique]
provoqué un débat dans toute la société
c'est l'ambition clairement affichée par
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui lors du
lancement des états généraux de la
justice à poitiers un rendez-vous pour
remettre à plat le système en 2022 et au
delà alors que la lenteur de la machine
judiciaire est régulièrement pointée du
doigt à commencer par la police elle
même dans notre rubrique en pensent les
français ce soir nous sommes justement
allé à la rencontre de policiers
marseille à qui le président a fait
beaucoup de promesses récemment
marine le pen a longtemps vu comme la
principale rivale emmanuel macron doit
désormais composer avec l'hypothèse eric
zemmour dans les derniers sondages le
président sortant toujours pas candidat
reste en pôle position la patronne du r
n est elle au coude à coude avec le
polémiste eric zemmour pour certains
leur rapprochement serait un choix
gagnant entre déplacement des candidats
annoncés fracassantes et clash
interposés retour sur un week-end très
politique avec théo coin bat
eric zemmour emmanuel macron anne
hidalgo yannick jadot et jean luc
mélenchon plusieurs des principaux
candidats déclarés ou non à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 se sont
affrontées par médias et meetings
interposé ce week end invité par robert
ménard eric zemmour s'est rendu à
béziers où il a tenu une conférence à
l'occasion de la sortie de son dernier
livre toujours pas officiellement
déclaré candidat le polémiste d'ultra
droite mène pourtant une série de
discours à travers le pays aux allures
de meeting politique poussée par le
maire de béziers à s'engager sur les
perspectives d'une alliance avec marine
le pen en février prochain le désormais
ex journaliste et chroniqueur a
rapidement balayé cette hypothèse
novisia la seule quoi qu'il arrive
seul ça veut pas dire solitaire syndidat
jeu d'arc sans union avec
potentiellement
non mais je vous répète l'élection
présidentielle ne nécessite pas tu veux
ce n'est pas une alliance de partis
comprenez la logique de l'élection
présidentielle la logique de l'élection
présidentielle c'est un homme et un
peuple c'est pas une alliance de partis
politiques que dit robert ménard aimons
ce char robert se trompe si la droite
radicale semble surnager selon les
derniers sondages les candidats de
gauche sont eux à la peine aucun ne
dépasse les 10% d'intentions de vote et
les perspectives d'union ne semble qu'un
lointain souvenir en meeting à reims
jean luc mélenchon a pourtant lancé son
nouveau mouvement politique baptisé
union populaire afin d'élargir sa base
électorale en vue de la présidentielle
mais rassembler la gauche semble pour
l'heure impossible au coude à coude avec
le député des bouches du rhône yannick
jadot n'a pas hésité à tancer les
positions anti union européenne du
candidat de gauche radicale
officiellement investie en fin de
semaine dernière mais à la traîne dans
les sondages
la maire de paris anne hidalgo n'a pas
non plus été épargné par l'écologiste
pour lui les socialistes ont je cite
montrer d'incroyables limite pendant le
mandat de françois hollande c'est donc
une véritable foire d'empoigné qui
s'empare peu à peu de la gauche et tous
les coups semblent permis afin d'en
prendre le leadership
exemple avec le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste soutient d'anne hidalgo
olivier faur monsieur mélenchon fait
cavalier seul depuis cinq ans et n'a
jamais voulu tendre la main à qui que ce
soit ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
construit l'union ce que propose jean
luc mélenchon c'est tout le monde
derrière moi c'est l'union pour les nuls
de son côté emmanuel macron à commémorer
les 60 ans du massacre des algériens
commis à paris le 17 octobre 1961 cible
de tous ses concurrents le président de
la république multiplie les apparitions
et les annonces depuis plusieurs jours
le chef de l'état très probable candidat
à sa succession doit cependant faire
face à l'explosion des prix de l'énergie
au risque de voir émerger un nouveau
mouvement social semblable à celui des
gilet jaune qui pourrait mettre à mal
son ambition de rester à l'elysée
à six mois de la présidentielle donc
alors qu'il n'est pas officiellement
candidat exe moore semble encore envie
de l'entendre 1 et toujours sans
toujours être au centre de toutes les
attentions le polémiste qui fait
vaciller la candy du camp des combettes
pardon candidature de marine le pen
robert ménard qui va jusqu à implorer
eric zemmour est donc marine le pen de
se rapprocher alors un rapprochement
peut-il se dessiner ce possible duo à
l'extrême droite pourrait-il faire de
l'ombre aux autres partis c'est l'heure
de notre face à face
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
pierre frédéric billets mer et l'air de
dreux sur ce plateau bonsoir pierre
frédéric b merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés à distance jean-elie responsable
national génération z z comme zemmour
bien évidemment bonsoir à vous et merci
d'être en direct avec nous on viens de
l'entendre le maire de béziers robert
ménard qui pousse eric zemmour à penser
à une possible alliance avec marine le
pen et eric zemmour qui ne veut pas de
cette union il a dit c'est une vision et
est un combat trop différent j'en ai
c'est pas que c'est une vision trop
différente et un combat être différent
c'est simplement qu'il ya des enjeux
particuliers pour l'élection de 2022 et
c'est en jeu c'est finalement l'union
des droites et aujourd'hui la personne
qui incarnent le mieux l'union des
droites on a pu constater c'est eric
zemmour on va demander justement notre
invité
aujourd'hui qui incarnent le mieux
l'union des droites alors l'union des
droites c'est un vieux fantasme de
l'extrême droite à l'origine est
effectivement laon il ya un combat pour
l'instant amicale entre les deux
extrêmes c'est-à-dire eric zemmour et le
rn on sait bien que ça sont l'addition
de ces deux personnes ne fera pas la
totalité des voix potentielles et puis
vous savez la droite existe la droite en
train de se mettre en ordre de marche le
4 décembre via le congrès ait l'air tout
on va y répondre sympa et puis on aura
un candidat de droite française un
candidat et on sera tous derrière alors
en tout cas la droite a trouvé son
candidat naturel et c'est eric zemmour
ça c'est ce que vous nous dites et
sympathisants d'eric zemmour vous l'avez
d'ailleurs dit dans une tribune
notamment eric zemmour lui écouter ce
qu'il disait justement sur cette fameuse
union de la droite c'était il ya quatre
jours
je fait renaître le rpr edouard philippe
fait renaître l'udf et l'eire n'a plus
raison d'être
à nouveau interrogé pierre frédéric bien
sûr cette sympathique petite sortie vous
êtes d'accord jean elie et les xénons va
tuer le à l'air alors que on le rappelle
a et on va en reparler il n'est même pas
encore officiellement candidat à cette
présidentielle
alors moi je dirais pas qu'il a tué le
leur je dirais que c'est plutôt l'eau et
l'air qui s'est fait tout seul et
finalement les aujourd'hui les militants
et les sympathisants
du des républicains qui eux sont
vraiment plus proche de la ligne d'eric
zemmour sur bien des sujets et bien se
rapprochent naturellement et en
sympathie naturelle pour eric zemmour a
d'ailleurs j'en profite puisque monsieur
monsieur le maire vient de dire que
finalement le candidat naturel serait
serait choisi au congrès c'est assez
amusant quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui il
ya même une enquête qui a été menée avec
un questionnaire alors on peut
questionner évidemment la fiabilité de
ce questionnaire mais on sait que eric
zemmour était à 67 % dans ses intentions
de vote dans ces questionnaires qui
était sorti évidemment avec une valeur
spécifique comme j'ai dit on peut douter
de la fiabilité mais on sait très bien
que au niveau de la niveau de l'offre
qui est proposé valérie pécresse xavier
bertrand michel barnier c'est des
personnalités qui ne séduisent pas
l'électorat de droite et donc c'est une
ondée droite n'est pas un fantasme
contrairement à ce que vous dites de
l'extrême droite mais est tout
simplement la seule façon de reconquérir
le pouvoir aujourd'hui est de pouvoir
proposer une de véritables solutions sur
les questions d'identité d'immigration
et d'industrialisation d'instruction et
eric zemmour n'est pas d'extrême droite
comme il le disait très bien il reprend
le programme du rpr des années 90 après
d'albi quand vous entendez
voilà ces propos de jean herry eric
zemmour feder et à droite une tradition
de droite vous vous en pensez quoi mais
c'est très rigolo l'avoir parce qu'en
réalité ce mouvement qui est un
mouvement politique pour le moment
reprend des vieilles ficelles alors hein
on cherche à déstabiliser les militants
en disant que les militants vont mener
par milliers chez monsieur zemmour ce
qui est complètement faux deux ont fait
des questionnaires des sondages pour
faire croire que ce sont des vieilles
ficelles et monsieur a raison les années
90 c'est bien mais c'est terminé on est
en 2021 il faut se réveiller il faut un
peu restaurée et rénover la politique
c'est pas que des les ficelles qu'on
fait on vous utilisez des vieilles
ficelles j'en ai ri en tout cas eric
zemmour les les utilisent c'est pourtant
sont son argument de dire voilà je ne
fais pas dans les vieilles tambouille
politicienne et pourtant on vous accuse
de le faire aujourd'hui
de faire des vieilles tambouille
politicienne dont je pense pas que ce
soit quelque chose qu'on puisse
reprocher à eric zemmour eric zemmour
n'est pas un candidat professionnels
comme on a pu le constater aux
républicains il ya des personnes qui
candidate ayant tout cas qui aspire à
être président depuis bien longtemps
aujourd'hui je pense qu'au tour d'eric
zemmour non seulement il ya peut être
une volonté d'être candidat mais il ya
surtout en fait un plébiscite je pense
qu'il ya un véritable plébiscite eric
zemmour en tout cas de la candidature
eric zemmour ne serait-ce que de la part
des républicains beaucoup d'électeurs
républicains moi je viens moi-même des
républicains derrière j'étais
fillonniste en 2017 et de la base
rassemblement national qui se
démobilisent finalement face à marine le
pen j'en ai ri d'ailleurs valérie
pécresse a répondu à cette question elle
a dit la candidate à l'investiture et
l'air dit que les sympathisants de la
droite feront le choix de la crédibilité
et crédibilité évidemment incarné par la
droite et non pas par le polémiste un
rajout tél il a ce problème de
crédibilité pour potentiellement diriger
un pays et l'hexagone
non non non il a pas ce problème de
crédibilité enfin tout dépend ce que
madame pécresse appelle un problème de
crédibilité si la crédibilité
aujourd'hui ça passe uniquement par de
la gestion ce que valérie pécresse fait
très très bien apparemment en ile de
france et il n'y a aucun souci hollande
est très bonnes choses à dire mais par
contre en fait la politique et surtout
la présidentielle c'est une vision
globale de la france eric zemmour ces 20
dernières années a posé les bons
constats amis les mots et maux ts sur
les mots emmaüs de nombreux français est
aujourd'hui la crédibilité je pense
qu'il n'a plus grand chose à prouver
auprès des français à part peut-être
qu'ils puissent acquérir finalement le
pouvoir suprême appuyé à frédéric abeba
grâce au gestionnaire uniquement selon
vous à
droite comme ça c'est dit c'est des mots
qui veulent pas dire grand chose dont il
est éveillé pécresse est une femme qu'à
un niveau d'une femme d'état qui
éprouvent qu'elle peut prendre les
dossiers très compliqué ce que l'île de
france est très compliqué comme aller
bertrand qui est un homme d'état aussi
qui est de très haut niveau car relancer
aussi la région de france il faut quand
même le remettre et puis vous savez vous
monsieur zemmour il va avoir une grande
difficulté en réalité deux difficultés
d'ailleurs la première c'est ne pas se
fâcher avec le rn parce qu'il cherche
bien à faire plier marine le pen qui ne
pliera pas est en réalité ils vont
s'auto détruire nombreux analyses et
puis la seconde chose c'est que monsieur
zemmour il va falloir qu'ils rentrent
dans le dur s'il est vraiment candidat
candidat par candidat en tout cas et
quel est son programme parce qu'il a une
réponse toute faite en disant je veux
être chef de l'état et je mets à ce
niveau là le débat oui mais les français
ils ont des attentes assez simple ils
veulent savoir où on va c'est vrai aussi
des solutions pratiques et là
malheureusement le bât blesse des
solutions pratiques j'en ai ri c'est
vrai que il ne suffit pas d'avoir une
vision de la france il faut vous le
savez avoir un parti derrière soi un
appareil en tout cas pour gouverner est
ce que c'est le cas aujourd'hui de
d'eric zemmour qui certaine vision de la
france mais peut-être pas toute la
machine nécessaire derrière pour pour
diriger un pays alors cessé c'est une
question évidemment il est toujours la
question et partira je viens juste sur
le petit sur sur pécresse sur les i
pécresse
puisque vous disiez justement que mme
pécresse est très très forte en gestion
et ce genre de choses et c'est
exactement fait ce que je reproche c'est
ce que beaucoup de personnes reprochent
c'est un petit peu comme alain juppé
alain juppé surjouée finalement ça c'est
à son rôle à la mairie de bordeaux parce
qu'ils savaient qu'il n'atteindrait pas
le pouvoir je pense que valérie pécresse
et xavier bertrand sur jouent leur rôle
à la région ce qu'ils n'auront pas le
pouvoir de toute façon n aspire qu être
d un premier ministre de de macron pour
ce qui est ensuite du parti je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les parties sont démodés
je pense que emmanuel macron normalement
vous a donné la leçon et nous a donné la
leçon à nous tous les partis sont
démodés surtout lors de l'élection
présidentielle où c'est la rencontre
comme dirait de gaulle de l'homme entre
un homme et un peuple et non pas une
politique des partis donc utiliser
l'argumentation fut en arguments des
parties pour justifier nous comment dire
une un manque de crédibilité pour une
candidature aux présidentielles je
trouve que en termes de vieilles
tambouille politicienne monsieur le
maire vous vous êtes bien tombé dedans
quoi alors on va vous redonner la parole
évidemment ainsi à frédéric mais on va
lire ce message un téléspectateur qui
rend qui entre ce soir tout doucement à
dents dans ce débat avant tout
faudrait-il que eric zemmour soit
officiellement déclaré candidat ça c'est
bien vrai démon qui sera certainement
faire ce qu'a fait macron c'est-à-dire
piocher dans les différents partis
politiques pour créer un gouvernement
s'il venait à être j'imagine au pouvoir
c'est ça doit être la suite du message
sarsat risquerait d'être le cas
finalement un eric zemmour à l'instar
d'un emmanuel macron qui part tout seul
et qui s'il devait être amené un jour à
gouverner le frais en piochant un peu
partie vous accepteriez vous d'être dans
un gouvernement de d'eric zemmour ou
alors très clairement non simplement on
savait eric zemmour aujourd'hui il a
deux grands leviers assez puissant pour
lui un il est seul sur la scène
politique parce que les partis
politiques ne sont pas encore en ordre
de marche ça c'est la première chose est
la seconde chose c'est que comme il
n'est pas candidat et bénéficier d'une
couverture médiatique monumental il a
utilisé les médias pendant des années en
tant que chroniqueur éditorialiste
intellectuelle etc il s'est fait une
belle image et maintenant il est dans un
espèce de vide politique mais tous à la
fin de l'année ça va être compliqué pour
lui les machines vont se mettre en route
et puis vous savez monsieur hery faut
pas mépriser je dirais les militants qui
sont là depuis des années les i de
locaux d'ailleurs les nerfs ont une
grande confiance des électeurs les
prises et tous avaient la france des
territoires est bien plus compliqué que
ça monsieur zemmour on le voit dans les
sondages fait des percées sur les
aspects les csp + en urbain mais la
france des territoires exister il faut
pas la méprise et janry à cette question
souvent la france des territoires il en
est loin et les héros alors non et non
eric zemmour est mauvais mais les
personnes lésées nourrissent de meilleur
général ne méprise pas ni les
territoires ni les militants les
républicains comme j'ai dis j'en viens
j'ai écouté les militants aussi et de
manière générale j'ai encore une oreille
qui traîne pour aller écouter ce que
disent et mi temps et je sais très bien
qu'il ya une sympathie naturelle pour
eric zemmour donc je ne pense pas que ce
soit mépriser les militants que de leur
dire que finalement valérie pécresse ou
xavier bertrand n'est pas le choix idéal
mais michèle bernier n'est pas le choix
idéal dans leur cas pour ce qui est du
reste et finalement des territoires eric
zemmour a tout de suite compris à
l'époque dès la première manifestation
des jeunes par exemple à quel était
soucis à qu'elle était l'essence de ce
mouvement et je pense que c'est
justement la compréhension des gilet
jaune comprendre en tout cas d'où vient
ce mouvement douceur ce mouvement que
finalement on pose un diagnostic et on
peut comprendre cette france des
territoires donc pour laquelle
évidemment les élus ump à l'époque n'ont
pas fait grand chose non plus
pierre frédéric habillé il est en tout
de même je sais que
esti candidats et leers se réunissent
demain pour un petit déjeuner il ya eu
plusieurs réunions s'attarde là vous
devez être vous impatient tant que
militant mer et l'air de voir enfin
sortir du chapeau un candidat justement
pour peut-être qu'on parle d'autre chose
que eric zemmour de marine le pen oui
alors il ya un temps nécessaire pour la
discussion c'est assez traditionnel à
droite d'ailleurs on voit les trop longs
certaines manquent c'est un petit peu
long c'est vrai il faut aussi avoir
conscience que les temps sont raccourcis
maintenant pour une campagne une
campagne électorale et notamment la
présidentielle on l'a vu six mois avant
macron été été n'existait pas dans les
sondages et six mois plus tard et des
prix dans la public donc je pense que le
temps s'est accéléré début décembre bon
c'est une date comme une autre en tout
cas ça permet d'avoir une durée
discussions la tradition à droite c'est
quoi souvent on s'engueule entre nous on
choisit un chef et on est tous derrière
et je vous les croyez moi que la machine
de droite quand les derrière un candidat
les redoute vous y croyez cette fois ci
parce qu on a vu ce que ça va donner la
dernière fois cette primaire dont les
déboires de de françois fillon mais
cette machine à perdre là vous l'avez
vous le craignez pas trop de même on
peut toujours la crainte simplement
quand on regarde les élections
régionales on est des très bons scores
aux municipales aux menus très bon score
donc il ya une assise territoriale il ya
des militants il ya beaucoup d'élus sur
le terrain qui sont là et qui montre la
droite et une partie de gens sérieux moi
j'ai pas inquiet vous savez la machine
va se mettre en route on va tous être
derrière il savait la grande leçon de
2007 c'est qu'il faut être extrêmement
modeste sur les résultats c'est vrai est
encore plus prudent avec les sondages
sont au mois d'octobre j'en ai ri
l'ailer qui vont se mettre en marche
bientôt eric zemmour qui va peut-être se
déclarer vous le craignez ça va changer
peut-être quelque chose cette dynamique
entre le candidat officiel l air et la
candidature officielle de d'eric zemmour
pourquoi il tarde autant bailleur or on
en est où les 500 parrainages et du
soutien financier
alors délit au niveau du soutien
financier les parrainages c'est des
informations qui sont communiquées assez
régulièrement dans les dents dans les
journaux au niveau des parrainages je
crois que c'était une source lepoint ou
20 minutes pardon avec avait dit une
plus de 200 300 je sais plus combien de
parrainage exactement donc ça a l'air de
en tout cas c'est des promesses de
parrainages évidemment ça a l'air
d'avancer au niveau des financements
j'imagine que c'est pareil il ya
beaucoup de deux ans on sait qu' il ya
des levées de fonds qui s'organisait
assez régulièrement c'est comme ça que
ça fonctionne comme pour n'importe
quelle candidature traditionnels pour le
coup ensuite pour ce qui est de retour
et véritablement l'instant où les
républicains choisiront un candidat moi
je pense que le parti choisir un
candidat les militants choisiront un
autre ce sera eric zemmour ou toute
manière donc je pense même que j'attends
avec impatience le moment où ils vont
déclarer un candidat puisque à ce moment
là les militants pourront décidément
nous rejoindre et nous les accueillerons
avec avec plaisir le mot de la fin
pierre frédéric ehui de choses alors la
première information c'est que bombes et
eghezée mois est candidat merci monsieur
hery qu'on lève des fonds encore
cherchent des parrainages et candidat
donc il ya plus d'effet de surprise je
vous remercie pea seconde chose voilà un
peu de modestie tout ça va se mettre en
route on va voir si monsieur zemmour à
un vrai programme pour les français et
puis on verra mais on a le temps c'est
faux de très modestes merci en tout cas
pierre frey dribbler d'avoir été sur ce
plateau merci jean mary d'avoir été en
direct avec vous merci à tous les deux
jusqu'où pourrait-il aller les fortes
tensions qui oppose la russie à l'otan
moscou réplique aujourd'hui au retrait
des accréditations de 8 émissaire russe
a lancé par l'alliance début octobre sur
fond d'accusations d'espionnage en
réponse le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a purement et simplement
décidé de couper les ponts avec l'otan
les précisions de notre correspondant
antoine claireaux à moscou la réponse de
moscou n'aura tarder que quelques jours
après le renvoi de huit membres de la
mission de représentation russe auprès
de l'otan les autorités ont frappé fort
la russie a décidé de ne plus se voiler
la face et d'arrêter je cite de
prétendre que de meilleures relations
avec l'alliance atlantique était
possible dans un avenir proche
nous avons pris les décisions suivantes
en raison des démarche délibérée de la
part de l'otan nous ne disposons pas des
conditions adéquates pour mener des
activités diplomatiques élémentaire et
en réponse aux actions de l'otan nous
suspendons le travail de notre mission
permanente auprès de l'otan y compris le
travail de représentant militaire en
chef probablement à partir du 1er
novembre ou peut-être que cela prendra
encore quelques jours
deuxièmement nous suspendons les
activités de la mission de liaison
militaire de l'otan à moscou
l'accréditation de ses employés sera
révoqué à partir du 1er novembre 2021 et
troisièmement les activités du bureau
d'information de l'otan à moscou qui a
été créé auprès de l'ambassade du
royaume de belgique prenne fin
les autorités russes voient en effet une
contradiction entre d'un côté les
déclarations des représentants de l'otan
qui appelle à une normalisation des
relations avec la russie et de l'autre
leurs actions cette mission
d'observateurs de la russie auprès de
l'otan avait pour objectif de coopérer
sur certains dossiers et ce malgré les
tensions entre les deux entités la
mission en question cessera donc ses
activités à partir du 1er novembre
prochain dorénavant pour contacter
moscou l'otan devra passer par
l'ambassade de russie en belgique et
pour xavier moreau directeur de strates
paul les accusations d'espionnage
évoqués par l'otan à l'encontre de la
russie sont une excuse les occidentaux
l'excusent de l'espionnage a été utilisé
de nombreuses fois par les pays de
l'otan justement sans qu'il puisse en
apporter la moindre un moindre preuve
donc je pense que non c'est surtout
imaginer que sur 18 membres de la
délégation russe noyé huit qu'ils soient
des espions vous ferez comme arrêter de
raconter n'importe quoi c'est pas s'est
passé pas très sérieux non non c'est un
acte purement hostile mais qui masque
mal d'ailleurs une
une impuissance de l'otan la russie a
achevé dans stream-2 la russie a montré
qu'elle est capable de tenir
tranquillement face à face à l'ukraine
et que désormais les les occidentaux sur
la plupart des théâtres qui applique la
russie sont bloqués et c'est eux qui
sont soumis au bon vouloir de la russie
et surtout au fait que le temps joue
pour la russie contre le contre les pays
occidentaux loto et on va approfondir
avec un claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir
claudin blanche maison
on le voit la russie dont qui gêne sa
mission avec l'otan après d'énièmes
accusations d'espionnage comme le dit
xavier moreau c'est une excuse et
finalement sans preuve je crois que la
première réaction c'est une réaction de
surprise parce que qui à part nous à
part les spécialistes savaient que il y
avait un ambassadeur russe à l'otan et
qu'il y avait une mission diplomatique
à à l'otan qui savait qu'en 2002 il ya
vu un sommet de l'otan avec la russie
qui avait défié de la création d'un
conseil
entre la russie et l'otan qui s'est
d'ailleurs réuni à peu près chaque année
sauf pendant un an ou deux au moment de
la difficulté sur l'ukraine et puis
récemment à côte la pandémie mais ce
conseil de coopération entre la russie
et l'otan s'est réuni régulièrement les
chefs militaires se voit le général
gherasim of a rencontré ses homologues
de l'otan chaque année très
régulièrement et par conséquent et bien
effectivement
probablement ce canal qui est suspendu
va peut-être disparaître c'est dommage
c'est dommage parce que ça permettait
d'échanger un certain nombre
d'informations les militaires pourront
continuer d'ailleurs à se voir sans
qu'il y ait de missions diplomatiques ne
serait ce que pour éviter les conflits
n'ont souhaité les conflits de rencontre
et je pense que effectivement et bien
cette mission qui avait été réduite par
le secrétaire-général de l'otan en effet
de 30 à 20 membres il y a un an et demi
et puis au printemps dernier de 20 à 10
et maintenant dans un stade d'attrition
qui justifie sa suppression alors votre
question c'est est-ce que ils ont
espionné ou pas je n'en sais rien bien
sûr on peut dire qu'ils ont espionné
bien sûr ce qu'on peut dire aussi que
c'est une décision purement politique
générale avait une excuse mais qui
arrange tout le monde et moi ce que je
crains c'est que l'eau aujourd'hui on
utilise le mot suspension mais quand en
réalité ça soit le mot suppression qu'il
faille utiliser car ça arrangera tout le
monde ça arrangera les ultras à moscou
qui dans le fond veulent ajuster leurs
actes avec les paroles puisque l'otan
c'est le mal pourquoi est-ce qu'on
aurait des relations diplomatiques avec
l'otan il vaut mieux avoir des relations
diplomatiques et négocier avec ce qui
compte c'est à dire les bêtas washington
et puis les états qui ont une influence
à l'intérieur de l'otan l'allemagne la
france
la grande bretagne quelques autres ils
peuvent aussi avoir des opinions
divergentes plutôt qu'avec cet organisme
l'a alors certains à bruxelles
aujourd'hui disent que ça va peut-être
plus loin cette rupture des relations
avec l'otan surtout après ce que
monsieur lavrov avait dit à monsieur
morel sur l'égalité de la représentation
de l'union européenne la convocation de
la représentante de l'union européenne à
moscou est-ce que ça n'est pas un
avertissement lancé à l'union européenne
à travers cette mesure très très très
très rude de suppression de toute
représentation est ce que ce n'est pas
une un avertissement pour dire si
l'union européenne poursuit sur la même
voie on attaque en permanence en
sanctionnant la russie et bien il lui
arrivera la même chose je ne le crois
pas je ne crois pas pour une raison
simple c'est que l'union européenne a
des relations techniques économiques
extrêmement dense avec la russie et que
le représentant permanent de la russie
auprès de l'union européenne monsieur
tchijov joue un rôle très important
depuis dix ans dans ce dans cette
relation dans ce rapport qui est
probablement techniquement
indispensable club blanchemaison à ce
que cette affaire c'est pas tout
simplement une nouvelle illustration des
fortes tensions qui opposent depuis déjà
évidemment plusieurs années on le sait
la russie et les occidentaux
oui sans doute temps doute c'est
effectivement
le l'illustration de l'évolution comme
je lisais dans les années 2000 il ya une
tentative de rapprochement pendant vingt
ans il ya quand même eu à travers cette
mission à travers la mission homologue à
moscou des tentatives de trouver des
coopérations entre la russie et l'otan
ça a échoué bonds est donc maintenant ça
n'est plus possible et effectivement on
est plutôt dans une phase
malheureusement deux confrontations sauf
peut-être en ce qui concerne les
relations encore une fois économique
entre l'union européenne et ses états
membres d'une part et la russie d'autre
part alors il ya beaucoup d'intérêts
communs évidemment le dis toujours entre
la russie et les états membres de
l'union européenne et des intérêts
communs qui sont pas seulement
économiques qui sont aussi politiques on
le voit tous les jours au proche orient
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée est
également le verra aussi à la coop 26
dans quelques jours à glasgow on le
verra ensuite au g20 au g20 de rome où
les dirigeants se retrouveront et sur un
certain nombre de sujets doivent
nécessairement discuter et peut-être
même tenter de trouver des solutions
parce que ces sujets ne sont pas
susceptibles d'être résolue à un échelon
national même à l'échelle d'un si grand
pays qu'est la russie merci beaucoup
claude blanchemaison nous avoir apporté
votre éclairage et la place de moscou
dans le monde en question au club
international de discussion valdaï un
forum qui a ouvert ses portes
aujourd'hui à sotchi dans le sud de la
russie qui se tient jusqu'à jeudi
prochain chercheur personnalités
politiques russes et experts
internationaux y participent sur place
les précisions de notre correspondante
maylis d'estrées c'est en effet
aujourd'hui qui a été inaugurée la 18e
édition de ce grand rendez vous
international
intitulé cette année bouleversement
mondial au 21ème siècle l'individu les
valeurs et l'état créé en 2004 le forum
réunit chaque année des chercheurs et
des personnalités politiques russes
ainsi que des experts internationaux
pour parler de gouvernance mais aussi
d'économie à échelle mondiale
nos réunions dans le cadre du forum de
valdaï ont pour fonction les change
d'idée vous savez la pandémie a causé
beaucoup de dégâts dans le domaine des
relations internationales
puisque vous ne pouvez pas vérifier les
informations et il y en a beaucoup qui
circulent
la question est alors de savoir quelles
informations sont dignes de confiance
et dans ce cas rencontrés en personne
des experts des quatre coins du monde et
peut-être le meilleur et le plus fiable
moyen de vérifier ce qu'il faut croire
est ce qu'il ne faut pas à cet égard le
club de valdaï est une plateforme unique
la session organisée aujourd'hui était
consacrée aux raisons pour lesquelles la
pandémie de coronavirus pourrait servir
de prétexte à la création d'un nouvel
ordre mondial une dizaine d'autres
cessions sont prévues ces trois
prochains jours sur des thèmes comme les
relations russo européennes
l'approché russe en matière de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique ainsi
que la restriction de liberté en période
de pandémie
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale cette reprise des
pourparlers entre le gouvernement syrien
et l'opposition des discussions sous
l'égide de l'onu à genève qui portent
surtout sur la réforme constitutionnelle
et sa mise en oeuvre un processus lancé
il y a deux en syrie qui connaît donc un
coup d'accélérateur adrien fonteneau
c'est une image que l'on n'avait plus vu
depuis janvier 2021 gear pederson
entouré des différentes parties
syriennes après un cinquième rendez vous
manqué en début d'année mais pas de quoi
décourager le représentant des nations
unies
ce comité s'est réuni 5 fu a déjà mais
après le 5è entretiens en janvier
dernier nous n'avions pas fait
suffisamment de progrès et nous ne
pouvions pas continuer à travailler
ainsi
aujourd'hui je suis heureux de vous dire
que nous avons trouvé un consensus les
coprésidents du comité sont d'accord
pour que l'on commence le processus
d'élaboration d'une réforme
constitutionnelle en syrie
les discussions vont donc reprendre ce
lundi et devrait durer toute la semaine
un sixième cycle de négociations
toujours en comité restreint avec 15
membres dans chacun des trois groupes
représentant le gouvernement
l'opposition et la société civile
pendant que nous discutons de l'avenir
de la syrie nous ne pouvons pas faire
abstraction de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain nous comprenons ces réalités nos
dates
depuis mars 2020 la situation a été
relativement calme en syrie et je dis
bien relativement car nous avons quand
même des civils blessés et tués chaque
jour donc ma volonté n'a pas changé nous
devons faire quelque chose pour régler
ce problème lui sans fin
mais comme je l'aï dit à plusieurs
reprises ce comité déterminant dans le
nouveau processus politique mais il ne
réglera pas à lui seul la crise syrienne
en coulisse malgré la situation
intérieure bachar el-assad travaille
également sur la scène internationale
des contacts renoués avec le roi
abdallah ii de jordanie pour la première
fois depuis 10 ans ou encore la
réintégration du pays aux systèmes
interpol sonne comme un retour
progressif de la syrie dont le concert
des nations
le discours en 2003 de colin powell l
onu a justifié le début d'une décennie
de guerre on ira 18 ans après le pays se
cherche toujours et tente de trouver une
certaine stabilité politique
dernière illustration en date avec des
élections législatives les premiers
résultats donnent le leader du parti
chiite moktada sadr vainqueur avec 73
sièges au parlement une tendance qui
déplaît aux opposants qui crient à la
fraude les détails avec valentin
carpentier
une déception immense ces images
remontent au 13 octobre dernier suite à
l'annoncé des premiers résultats des
élections législatives en irak
et des premiers résultats donnant
vainqueur le parti du leader chiite
moktada sadr mais qui ont aussitôt donné
lieu à des accusations de fraude
via des voix qui ont été volés à de
nombreuses personnes charitables des
régions de chasse à l'arabe à alpha ou
qui ont été volés et donner à des
personnes corrompues
la fraude était global ils ont exclu la
plupart des compétences et pour cela
nous exigeons une nouvelle fois que la
commission se réveille de sa négligence
et restitue le droit à ses propriétaires
afin de ramener le calme dans la rue
si des doutes persistaient encore sur la
victoire du leader chiite ils ont
presque été tous dissipés ce dimanche
après la révélation des résultats
préliminaires par la haute commission
électorale irakienne
et pour anticiper toute accusation la
commission a voulu faire preuve d'une
totale transparence
tous les résultats préliminaires pour
tous les bureaux de vote à travers
l'irak sont disponibles pour tous
puisqu'ils sont publiés sur le site
officiel de la commission en ce moment
et pour assurer la transparence du
processus électoral et pour préserver
les votes des électeurs et les droits
des candidats dans les scrutins nous
avons annoncé les résultats après les
avoir vérifiées calculé confronter
devant les médias les observateurs
internationaux et nationaux à moi çà et
là
[Musique]
si plus de 3 millions doivent encore
être dépouillée moktada sadr a agrandi
son avance avec 73 sièges au parlement
mais les partis pro iran auront tout de
même une influence notamment grâce à la
percée de l'alliance de l'état de droit
de l'ancien premier ministre nouri
al-maliki qui revendique une trentaine
de sièges
malgré cela certains partis ont annoncé
rejeter les résultats préliminaires
plus de 200 plaintes ont déjà été
enregistrés depuis l'annoncé des
résultats une escalade des tensions
alors que la cour suprême doit encore
valider les chiffres du scrutin
et on prend présent la direction des
états unis où colin powell est décédé
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 84 ans l'ancien
secrétaire d'état américain sous george
bush est mort de complications liées aux
kovy 19 on retrouve thomas bonnet en
direct de washington
bonsoir thomas et cette disparition
touba qui suscite beaucoup de réactions
aujourd'hui aux états unis
oui les hommages s'enchaînent depuis
l'annnonce ce matin aux états unis du
décès de collines powell une annonce qui
a été faite sur les réseaux sociaux par
la famille de l'ancien secrétaire d'état
américain qui a expliqué donc que colin
powell était décédée suite à des
complications liées aux comics 19 tout
en précisant qu'ils avaient été
pleinement vacciner alors colline peau
elle a servi pendant plus de trente ans
au sein de l'armée américaine avant
d'être nommé chef d'état major des
armées de 1989 à 1993 il est à ce moment
là le premier afro américain à occuper
cette fonction et puis en l'an 2000 le
président républicain fraîchement élu
georges w bush le choisi pour occuper le
rôle de secrétaire d'état américain le
chef de la diplomatie des états unis et
c'est avec ce statut qu'il va prononcer
son discours le plus célèbre mais aussi
le plus controversé c'était le 5 février
2003 au conseil de sécurité
l'onu colline peau elle expose ceux qui
sont censés être des preuves de
possession par l'irak d'armes de
destruction massive on a tous en mémoire
cette photo devenue célèbre de cette
fausse violent d'anthrax entre les mains
de colin powell elle est devenue le
symbole des mensonges américain pour
justifier l'intervention militaire en
irak dix ans plus tard colline peau elle
finira par revenir sur cet épisode dans
un livre il explique que c'est une tâche
sur sa réputation il critique aussi les
travaux des agences de renseignement qui
l'ont conduit à tenir ce discours il
n'ya pourtant jamais eu de véritables
enquêtes qui ont été menées sur les
dessous de ce discours qui a donc permis
l'intervention militaire des etats-unis
en irak alors aujourd'hui on est un peu
loin des polémiques évidemment l'heure
est plutôt aux hommages qui se succèdent
depuis ce matin que ce soit le
secrétaire américain à la défense où
évidemment le georges de bonis bush qui
ont partagé à leurs émotions je vous
propose de les écouter
laura et moi sommes profondément
attristés par la mort de collines powell
il a été un grand serviteur du pays dès
le début en tant que soldats engagés
dans la guerre du vietnam
de nombreux présidents se sont reposés
sur les conseils et l'expérience du
général powell il était tellement
apprécié des présidents qu'il a reçu la
médaille présidentielle de la liberté à
deux reprises et plus important encore
que line était un homme dévoué à sa
famille mais aussi un ami
le monde a perdu l'un des plus grands
dirigeants que nous ayons connue
alma a perdu un grand marie et la
famille a perdu un père formidable
j'ai perdu un ami personnel et un mentor
extraordinaire
elle a servi un président républicain
george w bush en l'occurrence mais il
s'est éloigné au fur et à mesure du
parti républicain puisque en 2008 déjà
il avait appelé à voter pour barack
obama et puis ces dernières années il
s'était montré particulièrement critique
à l'égard de donald trump est d'ailleurs
en 2020 il avait appelé à voter pour joe
biden on sait que les deux hommes sont
très proches et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'on peut ressentir dans le communiqué
qui a été publié il ya quelques instants
par la maison blanche beaucoup d'émotion
évidemment de la part de jo bail de
n'écouter
gilles et moi sommes profondément
attristés par le décès de notre cher ami
et d'un patriote à l'honneur et à la
dignité inégalée le général colin powell
du haut de sa position aux premières
loges de l'histoire conseillant les
présidents et façonnant les politiques
de notre nation coline a dirigé avec son
engagement personnel les valeurs
démocratiques qui font la force de notre
pays à maintes reprises il a fait passer
le pays avant lui même avant le parti
avant tout le reste en uniforme et en
dehors et cela lui a valu le respect
universel du peuple américain pour cet
héritage assez paradoxal finalement de
collines paul salué d'un côté évidemment
pour sa carrière militaire et politique
mais pour beaucoup il restera à jamais
comme le paie la personne qui a plaidé
publiquement pour l'intervention
militaire en irak qui on le sait a causé
la mort de plusieurs milliers de
personnes merci beaucoup thomas bonnin
en direct de washington et on va plus
loin avec notre grand reporter arte
france régis le sommier bonsoir régis
alors vous avez été vous en contact
direct avec colin powell puisque vous
l'avais interviewé plusieurs fois dans
votre carrière est la sienne d'ailleurs
quelle impression vous a laissé cet
homme qui avait quand même débuté sa
carrière sans kennedy a frappé oui tout
à fait moi j'ai interviewé ou au
secrétariat d'état à l'époque quand il
était donc en charge de la politique
étrangère américaine
ce qui était intéressant c'est que
j'avais eu l'occasion aussi de le suivre
dans une tournée diplomatique on était
allé en bio en bulgarie en hollande et
au maroc donc est suivi powell
l'impression qui m'a laissé c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours été
effectivement un serviteur fidèle c'est
ce qu'on dit un serviteur fidèle qui est
capable d'avaler les couleuvres ce que à
l'époque je précise la date de tout ça
c'était la fin de sa mandature on était
en 2006 condolezza rice allait prendre
sa place et
on a abordé tout un tas de questions sur
lesquelles il m'a répondu de façon très
diplomatique
et puis quand on a parlé de ce fameux 13
février 2003 vous savez le l'époque où
il a brandi cette fiole et il a lu des
rapports que il s'avère erronée alors il
dit à l'époque nous à nous nous devions
croire les agences mais il m'a avoué
j'ai senti qu'il y avait un élan de
sincérité dans sa voix que s'était il
m'a dit lowey spoints ma carrière c'est
à dire le pire moment de ma carrière on
dans le sens qu'ils en avaient presque
honte de ce moment il l'a répété
plusieurs fois j'avais eu l'occasion de
lui en reparler par la suite et puis en
plus c'est évidemment son mano a mano
avec dominique de villepin dont on se
souvient et qui ont fait finalement
l'histoire de la diplomatie mondiale et
qui ont marqué finalement le fait que la
france est opposée à cette guerre et que
les américains ils sont allés alors
powell a toujours eu des réticences sur
cette guerre c'est quand même
intéressant parce que à cette époque là
il était entouré de szczesny il est
entouré de vol faut vite de donald
rumsfeld faut pas oublier donc les ce
qu'on appelle les faucons de
l'administration et lui apparaissait
comme une figure plus mesuré et puis il
ya une un épisode très intéressant qui
est méconnue chez lui c'est à la veille
de l'invasion en irak en mars 2003
george bush qui avait bien avoir quand
même les était déterminé à faire cette
guerre mais quand même qui met bien
avoir un peu tous les avis convoque
powell à la maison blanche est élu dans
son bureau et lui dit colline qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous en pensez deux au
fond de vous-même dites moi parlez-moi
vrai et dites moi ce que vous en pensez
et coline powell lui ai dit c'est la
règle du magasin de porcelaine si tu
casses quelque chose cette chose tu
appartiens en parlant de l'irak je crois
que c'est la meilleure définition qu'on
est à mon avis à ce jour de cette
tragédie irakienne et de 7,2 cette
aventure militaire américain américaine
qui a coûté 2 trillions de dollars qui a
foutu le pays en ruines et qui a surtout
ouvert une boîte de pandore au
djihadisme on commandant
dans tout le monde arabe donc voilà la
règle du magasin de porcelaine si vous
casser quelque chose cette chose vous
appartient il a été difficile pour lui
de prononcer ce discours à la tribune de
l'onu ça aurait pu être éviter justement
sens mensonge 7 studios l'un d'eux
brandit devant tout le monde cette
guerre en irak finalement il l'a servi
quelque part il a été
finalement la personne qui aurait pu
dire non si on avait une avec sa
respectabilité avec son pedigree de
général qui a été rappelé sa carrière
impeccable sans tache le fait qu'il ait
été le chef d'état-major des armées
qu'il est d'ailleurs servi plusieurs
administrations avant ses origines aussi
un modeste gamins du bronx qui
travaillait dans un magasin de d2 copain
de ses parents fin qui s'est fait tout
seul je pense que il aurait pu en
appeler finalement une forme de
sincérité il a été embarqué dans la
machine républicaine à l'époque dans
cette espèce de détermination qui
avaient tous les autres piliers de
l'administration à vouloir faire cette
guerre absolument et powell n'a pas pu
résister il l'a servi et ça ça restera
comme il le dit lui même la tâche sur sa
carrière il a d'ailleurs plusieurs fois
traité 1 bouche de menteur et s'est
rapproché à militer d'ailleurs pour
l'élection de barack obama oui ça avait
été une des grandes surprises au moment
de l'élection d'obama ou powell avait
voilà d'une certaine façon peser
peut-être sur les républicains modérés à
l'époque pour que la candidature de
barack obama le l'emportent quelque part
powell a été le premier obama il avait
été question souvenez-vous que powell se
présente aux présidentielles aussi à
l'époque on avait dit c'est sa femme qui
n'a pas voulu voix la
liste mais en tout cas ça a été débattue
ce avait été voilà c'était une des
équations à l'époque que pau elle se
présente aux présidentielles américaines
merci beaucoup rêver sa vie pour cet
éclairage merci à vous
la politique est présent en côte
d'ivoire avec laurent gbagbo qui signe
son grand retour l'ancien chef d'état
ivoirien en exil pendant une décennie
est lancé ce week-end son nouveau parti
avec pour ligne de mire l'élection
présidentielle de 2025 avaya souple et
après dix ans d'absence il fait son
grand retour sur le devant de la scène
politique laurent gbagbo ancien
président de la côte d'ivoire a lancé ce
dimanche à abidjan un nouveau mouvement
le parti des peuples africains côte
d'ivoire dont il est devenu le leader
moi j'ai fait à paul plus que jusqu'à ma
mort
mais
main
et je le dirai à la fin de ce discours
c'est moi et moi seul
qui décide et sous quelle forme
je fais la politique
tintin nous sommes dans des micro états
comme ça nous ne sommes rien
ceux des lacs pas
l'idée de pas notre cas nous le parti de
l'ancien président se revendique
socialiste souverainiste est mise
essentiellement sur le panafricanisme
un nouveau parti qu'ils souhaitent
utiliser comme un instrument de combat
et qui nécessitent des alliés afin de
peser sur l'échiquier politique face à
deux grandes puissances telles que les
états unis ou encore l'europe
son objectif que les états africains
s'unissent
père fondateur du front populaire
ivoirien en 1982 le mandat présidentiel
de laurent gbagbo est marqué par une
crise économique et politique lorsqu'il
refuse en 2010 d'admettre sa défaite
face à son opposant alassane ouattara
actuel président condamné par la cour
pénale internationale de la haye il a
été incarcéré de 2011 à 2019 pour crimes
contre l'humanité
puis acquitté en 2019 une décision
confirmée en mars dernier
mais ces péripéties judiciaires
n'empêche pas ses ambitions politiques
aujourd'hui même s'ils se préparent à
passer le flambeau en douceur
l'insulté du parti que j'ai voulu
que je vous ai proposé
c'est une suture
pour préparer mon retrait
s'est plus quittés
ok
demain
je pu s'en aller tranquillement dans mon
bus l'un sans regret
laurent gbagbo laisse planer le doute
quant à une candidature pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle de
2025 de son côté le parti au pouvoir
joue la carte de l'apaisement face à son
rival et se dit ouvert à un renforcement
des liens avec le parti panafricain dans
un but de cohésion sociale et de paix on
est toujours en côte d'ivoire la menace
terroriste est plus que jamais
d'actualité ce alors que le procès des
attentats de grand-bassam doit se tenir
prochainement attaque revendiquée par le
groupe jihadiste al qaïda au maghreb
islamique avaient fait une vingtaine de
morts en 2016 cinq ans après les
blessures sont toujours vives dans cette
station balnéaire prisée par les
ivoiriens reportage abidjan de notre
correspondante lit la femme en sous ce
13 mars 2016 il est l'heure du déjeuner
et les plages sont gourmands les
assaillants ouvrent le feu sur les
touristes et les clients venus profiter
de leur dimanche ici à grand bassam les
stations balnéaires
une quarantaine de km dames de cantine
entre le d'espérer avoir appuyé en temps
parce que ces gens il faut reconnaître
que les proches de bruit le plein de
monde après le monde et tout d'un coup
aux environs de 13 heures en train de
coups de feu
au départ on s'attendait pour les
pétards c'est après qu'on a et
l'approximation que c'était une attaque
jihadiste est déjà vu les gens pour des
faits de débandade partout avec déjà un
arbre trois personnes en armes ils
commencent à tirer une vision
apocalyptique alassane ne parvient pas à
effacer de sa mémoire
trouver avec eux
est légaliste qui sait faire battre nous
mêmes ici un des premiers 3 décidément
c'est non
je
au total la barque et plus de carnage
l'attaqué fera dix neuf morts et 33
blessés et pour grand bassam au père
lui-même le traumatisme psychologique un
s'ajoutent les conséquences économiques
nous sommes des victimes à part entière
aujourd'hui le look l'aj auxerre de plus
en plus vite
après cinq années de procédures et des
investigations qui ont mené les
enquêteurs dans plusieurs pays notamment
la manie le procureur de la république
promet que toute la lumière sera faite
sur cette attaque mais il prévient déjà
il sera difficile pour toutes les
victimes d'obtenir des réparations
financières
nos fautes de l'ordre ont neutralisé
tous les assaillants et on sait aussi
que tout l'attak a été préparé a été
menée depuis un autre pays pour être
exécutée en côte d'ivoire donc il est
presque illusoire d'obtenir réparation
pour les autorités ivoiriennes
l'objectif des assaillants était double
a ciblé des occidentaux et porter
atteinte à la cohésion nationale
quand on regarde même le profit des
victimes et les les blessures qui ont
été cousus les victimes surtout
ivoirienne et à d'abord les trois forces
spéciales les enfants les jeunes c'est
surtout dans le dos
mais les victimes et européennes
notamment les français les quatre
français la macédoine donne yens
l'allemande qui étaient là ça laisse du
but ils ont tiré essentiellement dans la
tête manifestement plus de vouloir tuer
beaucoup d'ivoiriens il voulait surtout
donner une portée internationale e acte
l'un des principes de toutes les
religions c'est tu ne tueras point alors
que eux et prospects par l'étui ribes
massive il n'y a aucune difficultés de
cohabitation des religions que du mois
aucune même quand les tories sont venus
et l'ont frappé on a fait la part des
choses chaque religions cohabitent avec
l'autre un très bonne intelligence et je
pense que ce n'est pas un acte
terroriste qui viendra ça paie n'est ce
pas cette cohabitation pacifique non non
je pense moi les autorités souhaitent un
procès pour l'exemple dans un contexte
sécuritaire marquée par la recrudescence
des attaques terroristes au nord du pays
à la frontière avec le burkina faso en
juin dernier la côte d'ivoire a inauguré
une académie internationale de lutte
contre le terrorisme ans avec un
objectif
intensifier le combat contre les
djihadistes au sahel et dans le golfe de
guinée reste avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du lens font par
emmanuel macron des états généraux de la
justice à poitiers l'inventeur de la
machine judiciaire en france est
régulièrement poté du doit commencer par
la police elle même dans notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français ce soir nous
irons à la rencontre de ces forces de
l'ordre à marseille
[Musique]
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire les véhicules d idée courageuse
des mots qui comptent
en soi vient des lignes ont aujourd'hui
une gauche extrêmement
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
est ce vrai que c'est le général de
gaulle qui vous a demandé de fonder un
grand journal on me confiait la tâche de
créer un journal indépendant sirius
c'était le pseudonyme d'hubert beuve
méry le tout puissant patron du monde la
lumière prix de la presse et ce qu'elle
n'existe pas
il est jeune empêche pas de gaulle lui
octroie de dépendances c'est une sorte
de porte qu'il ouvre à beuve méry pour
l'appeler à des fins plus large destin
le général supportait très mal les
critiques de sirius et sirius
n'appréciez pas l'exercice solitaire du
pouvoir du général un combat âpre entre
celui qui décide et celui qui analyse
non c'était quelqu'un
c'était c'est intéressante
ce pays et avec l'ue
comment savoir qui on a tous y aura les
gens surtout
les ong sont devenus 50 ans des acteurs
incontournables de la société moderne
par leur impact auprès des gouvernements
et du public confondant régulièrement
les grands principes avec leurs
objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le ratio
le sectarisme de la majorité d'entre
elles les amènent à des interprétations
qui exclut toute pensée ou comportements
n'allant pas dans leur sens et leur
condition n'hésitant pas à tordre les
faits et utiliser tous les moyens pour
imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon le
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul vers moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel qu il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays en bien sûr partout partout
vous avez construit des usines
décarbonés vos des usines roues on
n'aimait rien du tout comme carbone dans
l' usine que ça soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde donc là
la conscience écologique aussi existe en
russie
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sort du politique il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu livre
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite c'était les gens
qui travaillent c'est les gens qui
avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose alors gens font-ils
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il ya eu celle et panama peppers les
paradise peppers place aujourd'hui aux
pandora peppers la plupart de ces de ces
opérations sont en fait parfaitement
légale y a rien de nouveau sous le
soleil on révèle effectivement un
système dans lequel il ya probablement
enfin incontestablement de plus en plus
de fuite devant l'impôt de plus en plus
de correction et de plus en plus de
difficulté des gouvernements avoir un
brin de contrôle sur ces masses d'argent
et qui circulent il pourrait simplement
arrêté au-delà ware ou dans d'autres
états comme ça de permettre ces
fonctionnements et c'est blanchiment est
ce que vous pensez sérieusement que
demain le dakota du sud va arrêter ses
pratiques et qu'on va lui faire arrêter
ces pratiques non pas du tout
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mapon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
sictom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule il est où ça n'a
plus rien depuis c'est pour se
rapprocher des jeunes mais parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup trop déconnecté de la
sphère politique il pense que ça va
ramener les jeunes à la politique dont
il se désintéresserait en lieu et place
de politiser les jeunes ça dépolitise la
politique pendant la rendant encore plus
qu on est justement c'est une nouvelle
forme de communication assez verticale
utiliser des influenceurs pour moissac
hommes politiques personnelles est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est vraiment
nouveau d'utiliser des célébrités pour
faire de la propagande politique on s'en
fiche nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige
la france comme si son travail en notre
nom pour nous est dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire le lancement des états généraux
'justice à poitiers par emmanuel macron
un rendez-vous pour remettre à plat le
système pour 2022 et au delà alors que
la lenteur de la machine judiciaire est
régulièrement pointée du doigt à
commencer par la police elle-même dans
notre rubrique enfance les français ce
soir nous sommes justement allé à la
rencontre de policiers à marseille à qui
le président fait beaucoup de promesses
récemment
redonné confiance en l'institution
judiciaire c'est donc l'enjeu de ces
états généraux de la justice qui se sont
ouverts aujourd'hui à poitiers jusqu'en
février prochain emmanuel macron appelle
les français à prendre activement part
au dialogue dans les semaines à venir
accompagné d'eric dupond-moretti le
président doit échanger avec des élus
des professionnels du secteur ou encore
des citoyens objectif proposer des
pistes concrètes pour faire évoluer le
système judiciaire souvent au centre des
critiques mais nous ne réussirons que si
la nation dans son ensemble s'engage si
les françaises et les français qui à un
moment de leur vie sont nécessairement
justiciables que ce soit comme victime
mise en cause ou partie dans un procès
civil se mobilisent voilà pourquoi je
souhaite que dans les semaines qui
viennent les lieux de justice
ceci est cabinet amphithéâtre les lieux
où la démocratie se tient partout dans
nos villes ouvrent grandes leurs portes
et que des débats puissent être
organisées partout sur nos territoires
voilà pourquoi aussi nous lançons la
plateforme numérique parlons justice qui
sera mise en ligne à partir
d'aujourd'hui et rassemblera en toute
transparence les contributions ont
provoqué un débat dans toute la société
pour réformer le système judiciaire
c'est donc l'ambition clairement
affichée par emmanuel macron une remise
à plat totale de la justice alors que la
lenteur de la machine judiciaire est
souvent pointé du doigt plus de
précision avec martial peuvion
emmanuel macron lens à poitiers ce lundi
les états généraux de la justice prévues
sur plusieurs semaines son ambition
dresser un état de la justice en france
et formuler des propositions concrètes
pour mettre la justice au centre du
débat démocratique
des discussions auront lieu avec des
citoyens des étudiants droite des élus
des professionnels de la justice comme
des juges des avocats et des huissiers
et également des membres des forces de
sécurité intérieure l'elysée précise que
des rencontres auront lieu dans toute la
france
les états généraux avaient été réclamés
début juin par de hauts magistrats
chantal arens et françois molins
inquiets des mises en cause
systématiques de la justice
la justice fait depuis quelques mois
l'objet de critiques récurrentes et
chaque fois un peu plus violentes celles
ci sont d'autant plus graves quand elle
émane des politiques qui devraient
pourtant s'attacher au respect des
institutions et ne pas être à l'origine
de la perte de confiance en celle ci il
n'est pas possible dans un état de droit
d'accepter que l'institution judiciaire
soit ainsi décrédibiliser et
déstabiliser la lenteur et le laxisme
supposé des juges avait été avancée lors
d'une grande manifestation de milliers
de policiers devant l'assemblée
nationale le 19 mai dernier le ministre
de l'intérieur gérald darmanin et de
nombreux élus et vert et rennes mais
aussi la maire de paris anne hidalgo
avait participé à ce mouvement
vient de l'entente des syndicats de
police trouve la justice française trop
laxiste et bien lente concrètement pour
les forces de l'ordre quel impact cette
situation peut-elle avoir dans leur
quotidien c'est l'objet de notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les français ce
soir nous sommes allés à la rencontre
des premiers concernés et policiers à
marseille cela même acquis emmanuel
macron a fait beaucoup de promesses
récemment un plan un milliard d'euros
pour la cité phocéenne quelle est la
réalité de terrain pour ses
fonctionnaires les promesses du
président sont elles vraiment tenu en le
reportage est signée sébastien dufour
avec david khalifa je suis à marseille
pour rencontrer et dc policiers et
membres du syndicat fo unité police
bonjour et dc merci de répondre à nos
questions
voilà on se trouve devant un
commissariat le commissariat du 12ème
arrondissement vous avez travaillé
durant plusieurs années à paris quelles
sont les différences notables entre la
police marseillaise et la police
parisienne alors déjà c'est le manque de
moyens effectivement c'est le manque de
moyens parce que par la somme en raison
qu'on a beaucoup moins de fonctionnaires
à disposition la banlieue proche a
beaucoup plus de moyens humains donc ici
on manque vraiment cruellement
d'effectifs de police première chose et
secundo si la leçon calibre a eu la
vidéoprotection la vidéo-verbalisation
serre que si on a très peu de caméras
aujourd'hui qui nous permet de pouvoir
lutter efficacement contre la dpc
délinquance de voie publique et ça c'est
vrai que c'est un manque de moyens
criant donc humain est aussi
effectivement technologique aujourd'hui
quels sont les besoins essentiels de la
police marseillaise c'est vraiment et je
le répète c'est malheureusement mais
c'est une vérité c'est vraiment les
effectifs ont là un tiers des effectifs
qui ont été promis on entend que les
deux tiers on espère qu'ils arriveront
courant 2022 c'est la promesse n'a été
faite par nos dirigeants on verra si
elles seront respectées le fait que les
labaki était pris pour cible la bac
marseillaise est ce qu est ce qu on a
franchi un cap dans la cité phocéenne
alors il est indéniable que il ya une
quinzaine de jours le salue tous les
collègues effectivement de la bac la bac
nord en l'occurrence ont été pris à
partie ont été mises en joue d'abord
effectivement dans un premier temps par
les individus ont été appréhendés pris à
partie ils n'ont eu effectivement la vie
sauve que grâce à la présence des murs
et d'aller à laquelle ils sont cachés
donc oui oui effectivement on a franchi
un cap pourquoi parce que nous gênons
les trafiquants et la stratégie du
harcèlement ne fait c'est le but harcèle
et j'ai mêlé les surveillants qui sont
je le rappelle aujourd'hui une manne
financière dantesque on parle de 30 à 90
milles euros par jour de chiffre
d'affaires par points de deal à
marseille alors il décide je propose que
vous nous emmenez un peu dans ce
quartier dit sensible ces zones on
appelle de non droit en tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle dans la cité
phocéenne oui avec plaisir effectivement
nous allons ne citons pas y aller
festival ya beaucoup à voir et à
découvrir la partie
[Musique]
alors qu'on est d'accord que le trafic
de drogue c'est un véritable fléau pour
la cité phocéenne mais est ce qu'une
fois que vous arrêtez ces trafiquants
qui est quand même de multiples
interpellations des sanctions à sont
assez lourdes sur le plan judiciaire et
l'avarice la problématique c'est les
places disponibles en prison ou les
mesures alternatives d'éloignement des
jeunes mineurs effectivement 30 ans au
trafic de stupéfiants pour leur éviter
de devenir des narcotrafiquants mais non
c'est pas ça
le monde 384
voilà je les ai rassurés ou les de
l'actualité bah ouais ouais à la célèbre
ils ont vérifié qu'il n'était pas la
police à gauche hormis certains élus ou
une idée c est de légaliser le cannabis
pour que les forces de l'ordre se
concentre sur les plus gros trafiquants
ce que c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise
idée honnêtement
d'avoir un discours aussi angélique y
aussi simple sur un sujet aussi complexe
qu'elle est ravie de stupéfiants c'est
vraiment être sur l'appel hors-sol
penser que les individus vent gentiment
se mettre à ouvrir des coffee shops a
essayé à payer des charges donc fallu
resaff ou ou payer la tva alors que l'on
fasse d'individus qui n'hésitent pas à
exécuter sommairement leurs concurrents
une fois que ces deux individus ont été
exécutés qu'ils en mettent si je puis
dire des balles dans la tête pour éviter
que leur mère les amasser une dernière
fois voilà les ihm du cool on a en face
de nous ce qui fait aujourd'hui la
rareté l'importance de la qualité si je
puis dire des narcos d'aider des
stupéfiants et des produits stupéfiants
c'est ce qu'on appelle au thc c'est à
dire en l'occurrence le taux de donc le
ce qui permet de planer vulgariser un
peu la chose et en général il est en tre
5 et 30 % approche plus les 30%
aujourd'hui ce qui est assez important
ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
narcotrafiquants la frappe donc si
l'état demain été amené ce que je
n'espère jamais voir le jour à légaliser
comme dans d'autres pays c était le cas
ils vont tout de suite influer sur le
taux de thc le problème du tout est à
chier c'est qu'en fait très simple oui
très simplement le tout est haché
effectivement il va le faire descendre à
5 ou 10% et autres les narcotrafiquants
se mettront à vendre ce qu'on appelle de
la frappe donc des produits avec un th
est beaucoup plus important qui sera
demandée par les clients
ce n'est à aucun moment probablement une
solution quelqu'un avec les puissent
être effectivement
voir ici on est dans une des cités un
peu chaude il ya des zones un peu de
non-droit aussi également comment ça se
passe le quotidien pour les riverains
ici et dans cette cité alors aujourd'hui
il y en eut cité des quartiers non et un
règlement de compte cet été une double
homicide effectivement à la kalachnikov
sur deuxième division à qui on a laissé
peu ou pas de répit ils ont été abattus
à bout portant est achevée effectivement
et ensoleillé agonisant donc cette
unicité effectivement ou des compliqué
de vivre surtout pour les habitants on
est un secteur dit populaire où
malheureusement le trafic de stupéfiants
un fait vivre toute une pente et pan de
l'économie et de la population
maintenant aujourd'hui des dommages sont
vraiment pour les habitants c'est
effectivement le cas échéant de balle
perdue ou malheureusement de dommage
collatéral possible et probable lorsque
les habitants de la cité pas ce moment
des faits en l'occurrence des règlements
de compte la préfète des bouches du
rhône cette semaine a déclaré que les
zones de non-droit n'existait pas ce que
c'est votre avis également alors à mes
yeux les on n'existe pas marché car les
forces de l'ordre dans tous les
quartiers de marseille et ça je pèse mes
mots dans tous les quartiers de carcenac
on écarte sud maintenant oui
effectivement il ya des endroits où nous
rentrons un seul véhicule il ya des
endroits où nous devons entrer à
plusieurs véhicules pour pouvoir
sécuriser les nous mêmes nos véhicules
travailler en sécurité pour nous et pour
les habitants dans un an tous se
demandent à faire emmanuel macron ça
sera quoi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
effectivement la demande que nous
faisons c'est que les efforts qui ont
été promis aujourd'hui soit accentuée et
soient concrétisées nous avons bon
espoir sur le cas mais n'hésiteront pas
effectivement la dénoncer si ce n'est
pas le cas un des policiers qui veulent
donc que les politiques tiennent leurs
promesses et surtout que le système
judiciaire soit repensé alors à votre
avis la justice et l existence vous pose
des questions ce soir vous pouvez réagir
sur le comté d g verte et france il est
encore temps puisque le débat est ouvert
[Musique]
tu es avec nous pour en parler ce soir
joëlle mélin députée européenne du
rassemblement national bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
aurélien lecoq orateur de la france
insoumise bonsoir aurélien nock merci
également à vous d'être là rama tout
d'abord sur le témoignage un convient
d'entendre il regroupe beaucoup de
sujets évidemment mais notamment la
question judiciaire qui revient souvent
dans ces conversations notamment chez
chez les policiers votre sentiment en
rien le coq ont fait preuve de parfois
d'angélisme
non je crois pas moi je ne crois pas
contrairement à ce que disent certains
syndicats policiers parce que c'est
souvent le fait de certains syndicats de
certains groupes que la justice
aujourd'hui soit laxiste jamais la
justice en france n'a autant condamner
jamais la justice en france n'a autant
fermé de gens donc la question elle est
pas là j'ai quelques chiffres rien qu'en
2019 on est assis 114000 condamnation et
à 280 milles condamnation qui se
rapporte à la prison et à 130 milles
condamnation à la prison ferme donc les
condamnations elles sont là elles
existent les juges font leur travail
après il ya des questions qui se posent
mais ils sont pas des questions qui sont
posées au système judiciaire en tout cas
pas sur la question du laxisme qui sont
posés plus tôt à l'organisation de la
police à ce qu'on fait avec notre police
est peut-être que effectivement plutôt
que d'envoyer nos policiers uniquement
pour faire du chiffre courir après les
barrettes de shit ou les petites
boulettes de drogue peut être qu'il
serait temps aujourd'hui de s'attaquer
réellement au trafic de drogue pour
s'attaquer réellement au trafic de
drogue il faut s'attaquer au trafic
d'armes il faut faire en sorte d'avoir
de la police judiciaire d'avoir des
enquêtes qui piste est mené pour
remonter jusqu'aux sources et puits sur
la question du cannabis oui nous le dit
on a une solution pour éradiquer
complètement le trafic du cannabis il
suffit de le légaliser et de l'encadrer
ce qui permettra également d'avoir des
politiques de prévention et des
politiques de sortie publique c'est vrai
que cette chronique suscité l'ouverture
à de nombreux débats mais pour revenir à
notre débat initial joël là pour vous
quand vous écoutez ces policiers sur le
terrain et de nombreux français
aujourd'hui on va peut-être en entendre
tout à l'heure vous pensez vous que la
justice est trop laxiste en france on
sait qu'une petite part du problème
comme nous l'expliquait aurélien lecoq
qui lui voit plus de problèmes dans
l'organisation même de la police
pour commencer pour pour être sur la
même tonalité que mon personne en face à
face ce soir je dirais volontiers que
l'angélisme c'est de dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'angélisme oui il ya de l'angélisme à
tous les niveaux et s'il n'y en avait
pas eu on n'en serait pas là mais il est
clair que la police effectivement et on
a entendu une fois de plus ce témoignage
juste vous dire que je le comprends très
bien puisque j'habite une ville qui est
périphérique de marseille et que la
délinquance qui n'est plus à marseille
et maintenant dans la ville où j'habite
où je suis élue donc évidemment le
problème est entier les forces de police
manque de moyens manque de possibilités
et surtout la situation est depuis
maintenant 25 ans tellement ancrée mais
les temps créé parce que la justice a
été à un moment donné alors je ne sais
pas s'il faut dire laxistes en tout cas
elle n'a pas donné les bonnes réponses
aux bourbons problème j'ai par mes
activités professionnelles beaucoup
fréquenté les tribunaux les tribunaux de
grande instance comme les tribunaux
d'instance il y a 20 ans on rentrait
dans les tribunaux comme on voulait et
puis un jour il ya des jeunes gens qui
n'ont rien trouvé de mieux que de sauter
au dessus de la marne du bureau pour
aller agresser le juge et ce jour là au
lieu de donner la réponse pénale qui
devait aller avec eh bien non on a fermé
les portes des étages où il y avait des
magistrats en mettant des systèmes avec
des codes alors que c'est tout les verts
ce qu'il aurait fallu il aurait fallu
que la justice reste libre et de ces
jeunes gens soient condamnés à hauteur
de ce qu'ils ont fait eux et par la
suite tous ceux qui nient d'une certaine
men hier ni le code pénal eni bien
évidemment le code civil mais ni le code
pénal si on n'a pas dans sa vie une
éducation qui vous donne les bons
principes les bons commandement
éventuellement porter par une religion
qui viennent doubler ça avec ce qu'il
est convenu d'appeler le décalogue et si
on ne respecte pas en même temps
parralèlement le code de vie le code
pénal du pays où on habite il est clair
qu'on n'en sort pas oui il faut
appliquer toutes les peines à hauteur de
la peine qu'elle soit dissuasive qu'elle
soit claire et qu'elle soit facile à
appliquer au-delà de ça a évidemment
donné les moyens particulièrement
policiers puisque le budget de la
justice a pu augmenter de plus de 30%
semble-t-il depuis cinq ans ce qui
semble beaucoup et pas beaucoup de sa
chandelle ou duo par donc évidemment
moyens techniques moitié humain est
aussi réorganisation d'injustice et
peut-être réorganisation d'une partie
des systèmes de police aurélien lecoq
évidemment je vous laisse répondre en
quelques secondes mais londres est
justement vous faire écouter l'opinion
de ces quelques français interrogés dans
le département de la seine saint denis
côté je ne pense pas qu'elle soit
laxiste mais je pense qu'elle n'a pas
les moyens nécessaires pour
véritablement travail on le voit en
seine-saint-denis nous disent qu'en
seine saint denis on a un taux à la fois
de délinquance et d'incivilité d'autres
choses qui qui est supérieure à la
moyenne et pourtant on a moins de
pouvoir et de moyens en terme de justice
on laisse tout faire maintenant on
laisse tout faire
ce qui mérite d'être en prison ne sont
pas en prison oh et puis bon la
délinquance allait
elle éclata les plus riches elles ne
vont jamais en 13 ans malgré tout les
délits qu'ils font et on prend les
petits pots d'un simple d'aider un délit
de rien du tout il se retrouve on
présents pour six mois un nom et voilà
aurélien le coquin c'est réactions
diverses en tout cas pour pour la
dernière ce sentiment ont certains
français que la délinquance augmente que
le laxisme parfois fait rage vous leur
répondez quoi à ces gens ils se trompent
ou on prend le problème dans le mauvais
sens
moi je crois que il est tout à fait
compréhensible il faut entendre le
sentiment d'insécurité qui peut exister
aujourd'hui dans le pays ce sentiment
d'insécurité d'une part effectivement
c'est un sentiment il faut qu'ils
répondent mais il faut aussi rassurer
une partie de nos concitoyens en leur
disant la justice et la la justice elle
condamne elle fait son travail et on
n'est pas dans un pays complètement
laxistes après sur la question de la
sécurité puisque il est bien là le souci
c'est les gens ressentent une insécurité
il faut donc pouvoir y apporter des
réponses pour ça il faut avoir une
police qui puissent être efficaces une
police efficace ça veut dire une police
de proximité une police qui ne cherchent
pas uniquement à faire du chiffre et à
noter le plus grand nombre de délits
constatés il faut une police qui puisse
connaître les habitants il faut une
police qui pour ça puisse être aussi
plus nombreuses travailler dans des
meilleures conditions et c'est pour ça
que avec la france insoumise avec jean
luc mélenchon on propose de recruter dix
mille fonctionnaires supplémentaires
dont travailler dans la police dans
l'administration qui paraît dans la
police scientifique également parce que
c'est important on propose également de
leur permettre d'être plus qualifiés
c'est-à-dire aux passants leurs
formations de 1 à 2 ans en augmentant le
nombre de centres de formation mais il
ya aussi d'autres soucis qui crée des
difficultés particulièrement difficile
au sein des quartiers populaires c'est
le chômage la précarité on est dans un
pays aujourd'hui on a 10 millions de
tonnes on a sept millions de chômeurs et
il est évident que la crise sociale qui
frappe durement le pays n'aide pas à
pouvoir vivre sereinement et à pouvoir
vivre dans un climat
agréable et et de solidarité donc il est
important aussi d'avoir une réponse un
retour des services publics partout en
france pouvoir avoir une politique
éducative volontarisme nous propose avec
jean luc mélenchon l'embauchent de 60000
enseignants donc il y a des choses à
faire donner du travail aux gens les
sortir de la pauvreté et leur permettent
d'avoir sur la question de la sécurité
des interlocuteurs de terrain qu'ils
connaissent avec une police de proximité
vous avez été nombreux à réagir sur ce
débat je vous propose de regarder une
première réaction de téléspectateurs
d'arte et france sur notre compte
télégramme elle est plutôt sévère cette
justice pour les petits mais son
principal problème est le cumul du
manque de moyens et la première nation
de loi dont le citoyen moyen n'est même
pas informés nous dit pascal des joëlle
mélin c'est un petit peu dans la
continuité de ce que nous disait
aurélien lecoq vous êtes d'accord avec
ce diagnostic également au cumul du
manque de moyens et un tas de loi
finalement qu on ne comprend pas bien en
tant que citoyen
tout simplement parce que les lois
existantes n'ont pas été appliquées
comme il le fallait et on retourne là à
la valeur de la peine c'est la peine
rien que la peine mais toute la peine si
on n'a pas besoin de faire des lois à
n'en plus finir il faut les appliquer et
les appliquer et qu'elle soit comprise
encore une fois ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure c'est que pour beaucoup
de personnes le code pénal n'existant
pas évidemment on fait n'importe quoi et
on est d'ailleurs c'est encore plus
rigolo quand on est dans la provocation
alors oui il y à un manque de moyens sur
ces manques de moyens on pourrait
peut-être aller les chercher en se
disant et je sais bien que ça va
permettre de réagir à à monsieur le coq
évidemment un prisonnier ça poutre 3000
euros par mois
mineurs isolés
étrangers
ça coûte plus de 3000 euros par mois
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois je ne
pense pas me tromper monsieur je pense
pas me tromper monsieur en disant cash
chaque fois c'est trois mois de retraite
moyenne en france ne pensez-vous pas que
on pourrait peut-être donner des
retraites aux veuves d'agriculteurs aux
veuves de commerçants et il ya toutes
sortes de personnes dont les retraites
et basse donc évidemment il ya des
budgets mal utilisé on pourrait déjà
trouvé les moyens en modifiant quand
même la possibilité de faire retourner
certaines personnes dans leur pays pour
y exécuter leur peine et pour que l'état
l'état régalien de chaque pays puisse
s'occuper de ses propres enfants c'est
la moindre des choses il ne s'agit pas
de dire qu'on est xénophobe ou que l'on
exagère dans ces conditions là cela déjà
est un point sur les 80 me sur les 80000
personnes qui sont incarcérés on sait
très bien qu'une grande majorité peut
relever de l'état d'origine d'hôtes il
vient sur les 58 11 ans relire le coq
genre est là mais là ça ne vous plait
oui sur les cinquante mille fini ma
phrase sur les cinquante mille mineurs
isolés une bonne partie si tenté qu'il
puisse avoir des papiers parce que
l'astuce consiste à ne pas en avoir pour
être repris sachez quand même que la
zone c 9 milliards d'euros le même
budget que la justice aurait l'air quand
la réponse j'en voyais alors on entre
ici dans toute la démagogie du
rassemblement national qui plutôt que de
proposer des solutions concrètes pour
aider les gens pour répondre à leurs
questions d'insécurité comme j'ai pu le
faire juste avant préfère une fois de
plus divisée attaquer et raconter des
contrevérités lorsque l'on dit madame
qu'il y aurait une majorité de gens dans
les prisons que l'on pourrait
envoyer je ne sais où c'est faux
aujourd'hui vous dites qu'il y à 80000
personnes dans les prisons effectivement
mais sur ces 80 mille îles ce n'est pas
une majorité d'étrangers qu'il ya il y
en a dix sept mille dont vous voyez que
ça fait pas tout à fait la majorité
évidemment la majorité des personnes qui
sont dans les prisons françaises sont
françaises ensuite tu compares vous
mélangez tout et n'importe quoi je ne
vois pas le rapport aujourd'hui qu'il y
a entre les mineurs isolés sont des
mineurs qui sont aussi dans une grande
difficulté avec les personnes qui sont
incarcérés vous vouliez que vous il
juste que vous dites que
la justice est laxiste et sans doute un
j'imagine que c'est votre idée que l'on
n'en voit pas assez de gens en prison et
à côté vous nous dites mais ça coûte
trop cher d'envoyer des gens en prison
où il ya un moment il faut l'assumer la
justice ça coûte cher la police ça coûte
cher mais si on veut vivre dans un état
de droit il faut être capable de s'en
donner les moyens les histoires
donnez-moi sur les prisons parce qu'elle
rassemblement national veut justement
construire davantage de places de prison
est ce que au rassemblement national
c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de
votre programme
non nous ne voulons pas qu'on sort des
places de prison mais surtout j'ai
l'impression que le rassemblement
national veut construire des places de
prison tout en expliquant qu'un
prisonnier coûte trop cher donc je fais
remarquer que j'trouve ça légèrement
paradoxal ensuite si l'on veut parler
d'eux de la justice et de la manière
dont on règle les problèmes de sécurité
la prison pour bon nombre de cas n'est
pas un problème on le sait aujourd'hui
le taux de récidive à la sortie de la
prison c'est 63 % des gens et c'est
malheureux à dire mais c'est la vérité
la prison fabrique de la récidive et les
taux de récidive sont bien inférieurs
lorsque l'on trouve des alternatives des
substituts à la prison donc oui si on
veut éviter la prison sur veut éviter la
récidive et si on veut se battre contre
la délinquance il faut aussi investir
dans l'éducation il faut aussi investir
dans l'économique et il faut arrêter de
se voiler la face en parlant toujours
uniquement de l'immigration de religion
parce que là il n'est pas un problème le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui en france
on a une crise sociale on a une
précarité rampante qui crée aussi des
petits délits c'est la réalité est que
la réponse clés précis partout tout le
temps le fait d'en fermer après on ne
résout pas la situation donc donnant du
boulot aux gens et réduisons le chômage
éradiquons la pauvreté créons une police
de temps des messages aureliano com
qu'est-ce que vous en avez parlé je
voulais vous faire terminer avec ce
sondage de l'institut csa paru fin
septembre justement qui montrent le
regard qu'ont les français sur sur la
justice une justice vu comme lente par
la quasi totalité des français mais
également opaque laxiste et inefficace
sondages donc c'est ça joëlle mélin
outre les messages sur une justice qui
donne dans l'idéologie
ça vous étonne justement ce regard des
français qui trouve la justice opaque
est ce que c'est votre opinion est aussi
et ça sera le mot de la fin on arrive au
bout mais écoutez on peut peut-être pas
malgré tout non laxiste oui on voit
quand même que des jugements pourrait on
ne pourrait cesser de réaménager toutes
les peines on pourrait faire les choses
très simplement une peine et qu'une
peine et on la personne qui est condamné
fait sa peine et on en parle plus en
revanche je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec monsieur le toc toc à une crise
sociale tout à fait importante que le
chômage que la précarité sont
véritablement des problèmes actuels mais
le sentiment d'insécurité monsieur qui
maintenant une réelle une réalité et pas
une perception flou comment disait
encore dix ans et les personnes de votre
de votre vision des choses disait que
c'était un sentiment est inventée par
les autres c'est une réalité tout cela
vient du fait que on traite les
conséquences et pas les causes monsieur
si vous voulez bien quand la drogue est
devenu une alternative au travail et que
l'argent de la drogue est devenue
l'alternative au travail effectivement
une société va très mal donc
effectivement la lutte contre la drogue
est tout à fait indispensable et
prioritaire et il faut donner à nos
forces de l'ordre quelles qu'elles
soient quelle que soit l'échelon de la
police ou de la gendarmerie
la sécurité civile leur donner la
possibilité de faire leur travail sans
qu'il y ait la moindre protestation
laërt les provocations sont tout à fait
insupportable et c'est la cause de
problèmes merci on revient le coq merci
également à jouer l'homme et l'inde à
voir en tout cas accepté de jouer le jeu
de ce face-à-face merci à vous et c'est
la fin de cette émission rendez vous dès
demain 20h10 il est là n'oubliez pas de
réagir de remonter de poser vos
questions sur le les grappes verte et
france prochain point sur l'actualité
dans une trentaine de minutes
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été au
pij